THANKS TO ALL OF YOU.
ANDERSON STARTCaptio b
TO REPORTING BWASHINGTON POST"
NIGHT AROUND THIS TI
"T R FAGENTS RECOVERED DOCUMENTM
FOIG
COUNTRY'S NUCLEAR CAPABITI
WHEN RCH WASHIFOR COMMENT,
IT.
INSTEAD HE SAID SOMETHING WE'VE
DEFLECTING FROM THE FACTT 24 HO
FOCUSING OTHAK
MARCO RUBIO SERVESTH
TTEE,
AWAY THE WAY FB
STFITS
EY THIS IS REALLY AT ITS CE AGEN
DOCUMENTS THERE.THEY DON'T DY H.
STORAGTHE DONE.
N APPARENT
>> THAT DOESN' LIKE THE
NDING YO
YOES
>> WELL, LET'S BREAK THIS DOWN.
T , AGAIN,E OW. BACK AND UNDE
THAT ALL OF  INFORMATION I
CONGM ONND
AT IS
KNOWLEDGE OF THE INVESTIGATION.
WHO ARE  E OF THE INVESTIGATIONH
MEDIA.
>> S TO DEFENSE,HEN, ADDED A IS.
>> YOU HAVI SPENDING
MORE TIME LEAKING STUFTO
PR
THESE PICTURESD
DOCUMENTS ALL OVER HIS OFFICE
V V
STAGED ALL OR AN OFFICE FLOOR.OC
S THE WAE
I E DO LEA
CE.KS IN THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
IT
TRYINGY THERE.
WHAT'S CLES HE TAK
TH WHAT SIFIED DOCUMENT, LET
WERE DOING AT HIS S RESORT.URT
SEARCH A FISHING EXPEDITION.DES.
>> H CLINTON HAD EMAILS THAT
SERVER.T OF THOSE WERE LAED
AT WAS DONE TOIL
CLINTON?
NOTHING.
ABOUT TRUMP O?NED ONCERNUT
WHAT THE FF ALL,
FORMER PRESIDENT.
STUFFECLNF
INTO HIS SOCKS A PIECES
NOTHING.ING IFORAND NOTHG
PING IN MIND, YOU
WANTTO
E FORMER NATIONAL
RIER PED GUILTY,
FINE, AND F SECUCE.
LISTEN TO WHAT FORIDENT'S OWN N
GENERAL SAID JTH>> I T I'VE SAI.
WILL THE GOVERNMENT BE ABLE TO
THEY COULD INDICT SOMEBODY ON,
CLHIM?'S THE FIRST QUESTION.
ANCLOSE
WHETHER THE FORMERDENT
HOPED NOT.
HOR,D THAT
WOULD BE CONSIDERAPR
TO DO IT B PEOPLE WOASSSND
DEE ABOVE LAW.
QUOTINBI THE
FORMER AORNERAL,
INDICTED, WHY NOT CT?TH FATRNIST
IDEA OF CHARGING A FORMER
PRT IS CERINTHETTING TO TH
LEGAL RAMIFICATIS, I WAN IN OURY
COUNRIVOICES
CLAPPER, CURRENTLY CATL CURITY
THESE DOCUMENTS THE HOLIES COME.
CAN YOU JULAY
F  A
GAIN ACCHE
WERE?
>> W ANDER I
WOULD LIKE TO SAS THAT
WE DON'TY KNOW THE
SUNT OF THESE DOCUMENTS.
YOU CAN AITHINGSFRLA
AND IN THIS PARTAR
MING
I SAID E.D THE ON SO  A
THEY'RE THHOLIEST OF
DECIDED THEYD  FOR THEIRVERY EX
IRONALISME N
HAVE IN H DECIDED AT DIFFERENT
TIMES THAT WE NEEDED NUC NT
AT ADVER.
RD
INTELLIGENCE PERSPECTI
KNOWLEDGE  TNTRY'S
CAPABILITIES AREELY
ANT TO  SECRETS TH T
A
TWO THINGS POLE
ONE, OF COURSE, ISO
KNOW ABO A FOREIGN NATION'S R D
T HOW WE GOT I
AND CLE IT
AND IT COULD
E THAT.
Y MEANS BYTUIGNORAF
D COUNTRY, THAS OUR OWN NATIONAG
DEAL.
AND ENIDE OF THAT
COIN IS IT ALSCO E THEN CO REIN
PAF  THEY'RE
DOING TO CONTINU
INFORMATION AN FROINING INSIGHTS
AND ANDREW, ONCE NATIONAL BE AO
WAINN THINGTONS
CLASSIFICATIONF OWS WOULD BE
THEY'RST TO BE A BIG
T CEY
AND NO FACT MAKES THAT CLEARHE C
RR SS
PROGRAMS TW MENTS.
SO, THES SO LID  DISTRUTN TO PE
NOT JUSTO SCI
AND SPECI ACCESS
PROGM AUTHORS E GOINRCD
THE RIGHT LEE TO
REALLY IESE DOCUMENTS,TO CONDUC
ASSESSMENT THAT ER
BOUT TO UNDERSTAND,
AVE WE LOSRE?ORST CASE SCENAR TT
ADVERSARY?D URCES AND METH
HAVE WE BETRAYHE OA ALLY?
EEN THE TOPINUCLEANA
T L RS COMPROMISE G ISUR
EXISTING IMPORTANTATIONSHIPS
WITH ALLIED TRIES.
VERY MANYOTENTIAND AT THE VERYS
YOU'VE GOT TO FIND THE
PELEH ACCESSESE
PROGRAMS T A
IT'S REALLD. DIRECTOAPPER, TRE
DE A
DOCUMENTS FOUNATO.SLY THS  OF
REG ON THAT SINCE ,
PEOPLE POINTING TH
OBVIOUSLY TOY ALL
THIS, WHILE
HAVE POWERS IN THAT ERE WOULD BO
IT.
ER PEOPLE WHO
RE INFORMED.TH.DOES IT MAKE ANY
CAPALINUCLEAR
>> WELL,S MAKE
SENSE.
FO
NONSECTOR TO SAYTO ASSERT,E
DECLASSIFIED SOMETHING AND BODY.
GOVERNMENT STILL BELIEVEAGIC WA
'S CLA